Here's what we're going to do that's
actually going to be even better than
dying one ninth at a time.
What we're going to do is we're
going to introduce a third party, so
here's Here's Smooth
>> Mm.
>> And here's Curly.
>> Yep.
>> And then,
here's my best sort of drawing of Chris
who's helping us with this class,
our course creator.
>> Course creator [CROSSTALK] I
like course creator better because
then it's CCC.
>> CCC.
[CROSSTALK] The course developer
CD which is on the screen.
That's true, course developer Chris,
OK we'll do that.
Does sound like a good hip hop name.
You know what we should do?
We should do some kind
of wrap of some sort.
>> You're going to have to teach me
because I don't know how to do that.
>> Okay.
Well, we'll talk about it later.
Okay.
So,
we're going to put our little CD here
and he is going to stand between us so
he's going to act as a kind of go
between, and what he's going to do is
he's going to make a decision for
us of a certain sort.
S, here's the decision that
we're going to have Chris do.
Chris is going to Write
down three cards.
One's going to say (C, C),
one's going to say (D, C), and
one's going to say (C,D).
>> Three cards.
Okay?
>> Yeah.
>> And he's going to shuffle those cards
and then pick one of them.
So in other words he
is going to uniformly,
randomly choose among (C,
C), (D, C), and (C, D).
Comedy.
Okay.
>> Yeah, yeah.
Okay, I get it.
>> So, you'll notice that's
three of the four strategies.
>> It's three of the four strategy.
Yeah, you're missing Deedee.
>> Deedee, which is the worst one.
>> Yeah, so you should put that one in.
>> No.
>> Okay.
>> Well, I could put it in and give it
and assign it a probability of zero.
>> But I like that you're their cards
and they have equal probability.
>> Right, they'll have equal
probability, so uniform choice.
All right, so are you with me?
>> I guess so.
>> Okay, so
Chris randomly picks one
of these three things.
Neither of us knows what it is and we
don't know anything about what the other
has but Chris gets to pick up this card.
And then what Chris is going to
do is something very simple.
Chris is going to inform one of us,
perhaps both of us, one after the other,
and Chris is going to, let's say for
the purposes of this discussion,
Chris is going to inform one of us
of what that person's action is.
Let's say Chris picks c,c.
Chris will turn to me and
will say, I want you to choose c.
Now, Chris would also turn to you and
say, I want you to choose c.
Okay?
>> And there's no conflict there,
because we can both chicken.
>> Do whatever you want to do.
I'm just telling you.
Here's what the card says you should do.
All right card says you
should chicken out.
>> And
he's going to force me to do that now?
>> No, let me do one more example though
before I really answer that question.
>> All right.
>> Let's say Chris had accidentally and
that is uniformly probabilistically
chosen the comma c.
>> Yes.
>> Then Chris would turn to me and
say the card says
>> You should do D.
Chris would turn to you and
say the card says you should do C.
>> But I would know that he was
actually just making me chicken out
because that's what people do.
>> No, that's because
that's what the card says.
Now let me be a little bit
clearer here because I wasn't.
These three cards
are known to both of us.
And we know that there's a uniform
probability of getting any of
those three cards.
And we trust Chris enough that he's not
going to always give you the good thing.
>> Yes, he's going to with
probability one-third.
>> Okay.
>> Do that, okay?
>> I trust Chris.
Look at that hair.
How could you not trust Chris?
Okay, so Chris is going to pick one of
these cards, and then tell each of us
what it is we're going to do or
what we're being asked to do.
>> Okay.
>> But not tell us what the other
person is being asked to do.
Okay.
>> So that's important, got it?
>> Yeah, that's interesting.
>> Okay.
>> because I can use inference.
>> You can use inference.
So in fact, let me ask you
what inference you should use.
So-
>> Bayesian inference, or
you didn't ask it, I'm sorry.
>> I didn't ask it.
So, in fact, I'm going to,
because you said Bayesian.
>> I didn't say Bayesian.
>> You just said Bayesian inference,
I'm going to make this a quiz.
>> As punishment for
saying Bayesian, okay.
>> Yes, how dare you.